being from a marginalized community
myself being a two-spirit person being
an indigenous person I know how scary it
can be to access care from the
healthcare field
dr. James macaques is not your average
family physician he's the only doctor
working with transgender patients in
anak First Nation a Cree Reserve of 2400
people in central Alberta many of his
patients drive up to eight hours and
walk miles along dirt roads to see this
two-spirit indigenous specialist who
makes them feel safe su spirit is a
contemporary English term to reflect
gender diversity that indigenous nations
have always had in our language we say
not less so not black means like ambient
being so if you think about energetic
forces inside a body it's like these two
forces that oscillate back and forth so
it's like it's not just male it's not
just female it's male/female back and
forth all the time
for the past three years dr. McLucas has
crafted his unique approach to
transgender care by bringing together
indigenous and Western teachings and his
biggest contribution is his openness
about his own identity
James has helped me accept myself
because he accepts himself he made me
feel comfortable in my own skin I don't
know what other doctor can help a young
boy become into a Cree warrior man
[Music]
you knock health center or muskeg Asik
which means where the medicines grow in
Cree is a 30 minute drive from Edmonton
[Music]
this is where usually can find stuff you
don't have much space I make it work
that's my little locker this is where
dr. McLucas sees patients from 9:30 a.m.
to late afternoon trying to make it GLBT
friendly so we have some rainbow
stickers everywhere this is the washroom
so it's a gender-neutral washroom and
because many in Alberta can't access
transgender care elsewhere they come
here to the enoch reserved solely
actually has a really important part of
her story where she was in a darker
place and it was very difficult for her
not accepting who she is as a trans
woman and that's something completely
different where she is today
when did you start on hormone October 26
22 2 what are some of the changes that
you know this I just feel myself finally
my anxiety has gone down I feel happier
I feel like I'm complete or on my way to
be complete I want to lived in fear in
secrecy being born in the late 50s and
growing up in the 60s 70s there was no
internet there was no one to talk to and
so I carried a lot of this inside I can
recall many times in my life or actually
thought of suicide and I'm glad I never
acted on it I come from a large French
Catholic family I always knew I was
different when I came out to my family
or let them in as I like to call it now
there was some painful things said to me
but they're all true painful things like
I was always withdrawn downer to be
around I accept Who I am and I am Leah
and I have always been Leah
some of the challenges of duty
transgender care is fear fear within the
medical community that were harming
patients fear that we are hurting
children or youth by disrupting their
their development and fear because we're
actually changing the physiology of
people since he was a teen doctor
Mikolka saw his cree two-spirit identity
as part of who he was but it was
different for his husband Anthony when
they first met he was still grappling
with what it really meant to be
two-spirit as indigenous people we have
always had gender diversity and sexual
diversity in our nations before
colonization existed on Turtle Island
[Music]
with the imposition of colonization
Christianity residential school as a 60
scoop a lot of those teachings of gender
diversity have been lost and a lot of
people are searching for their identity
as two-spirit people and the roles and
responsibilities that come with that
we're often like oh man what is it like
not to be native because other people
are talking about trips or nature or
whatever and we're like talking about
you know opioid crisis we're talking
about suicide we're talking about you
know very difficult things that we deal
with in our community by 4:30 in the
afternoon dr. McLucas is scheduled is
only getting busier his on his way to
the South's common Medical Center for
back-to-back appointments till 8:00 p.m.
all right so here's our clinic in South
Kona he's the only specialist who can
prescribe hormones and other trans
medicine there so he's gonna get settled
in and then start seeing patients right
away so for him the long hours are all
worth it remind me again you've done
testosterone for almost three years yeah
three years and then I first started
seeing you when you were 11
remembering my very first testosterone
shot it's almost like it happened
yesterday it solidified that I'm going
to be here that gave me hope
he told us right after he turned 11
really nonchalantly of course we reacted
as it was normal and we're expecting it
actually use the word gender dysphoria
which I had to look up after it
we wanted to be known as a boy
acknowledged as a boy and he had a list
of names for us to help him pick to
transition into becoming a man Emery was
bullied from the ages of grade one to
four and so he had serious bladder
issues because the bullying happened in
the bathroom it took dr. McLucas to
advocate and really respond and
acknowledge that the physical issues my
son had was a result of my son holding
his bladder from bullying that happened
for many years in a school being
two-spirit in my community means that I
am fully Who I am
I'm not shy about that I don't pretend
to be someone else two-spirit people are
very gifted individuals and they can do
many different things if people don't
stifle their growth and development
[Music]
you